WE'LL UPDATE YOU ON WHERE IT IS
AS OF TONIGHT.
WE'LL TALK TO JORGE RAMOSE JUST
AHEAD, BUT FIRST.
WE'VE GOT A FOX NEWS ALERT FOR
YOU.
A SHOOTING HAS OCCURRED AT
YOUTUBE'S CALIFORNIA
HEADQUARTERS.
THE SHOOTER APPARENTLY IS A
WOMAN.
>> WE JUST GOT A PRESS UPDATE
FROM THE POLICE CHIEF HERE.
GOOD EVENING.
JUST A HORRIFIC SCENE HERE TODAY
AT THE HEADQUARTERS OF YOUTUBE
AFTER A SHOOTER OPENED FIRE AND
SAID THE FACILITY DURING THE
LUNCH HOUR.
THIS INCIDENT LEFT FOR VICTIMS
INJURED.
THEY ARE NOW BEING TREATED AT
LOCAL HOSPITALS.
POLICE SAY THEY ALSO FOUND A
WOMAN THEY SUSPECT WAS THE
SHOOTER DEAD OF A SELF-INFLICTED
GUNSHOT WOUND.
OFFICERS JUST ANNOUNCED THAT
THEY HAVE COMPLETED THEIR
INTENSIVE SEARCH OF THIS MASSIVE
FACILITY AND DON'T THINK THERE
ARE ANY OTHER SUSPECTS OR
VICTIMS.
POLICE SAY THEY HAVE RECOVERED A
HANDGUN.
POLICE SAY THEY SAW A WOMAN TAKE
AIM AT A MAN WHO MAY HAVE BEEN
HER BOYFRIEND BEFORE TURNING THE
GUN ON HERSELF.
THE NAMES HAVE NOT BEEN
RELEASED.
WE UNDERSTAND ONE MAN IS IN
CRITICAL CONDITION, BUT IT IS
UNCLEAR WHETHER HE WAS THE
INTENDED TARGET.
IT'S A VERY TRAGIC AND SCARY DAY
HERE IN SAN BRUNO.
BACK TO YOU.
>> Tucker: CLAUDIA, THANK YOU.
FEMALE SHOOTERS TO EXIST, BUT
THERE ARE MUCH RARER THAN MALE
SHOOTERS.
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE PROFILE?
HOW OFTEN HAVE YOU SEEN SO THEY
LIKE THIS OVER THE COURSE OF
YOUR CAREER?